bonjour Grand Satan d'Amérique comment
allez-vous je vais bien merci au nom de
la nation de wadiya je suis scandalisé d'
avoir été banni des Oscars
par l'Académie des arts cinématographiques
et les sionistes alors que j'applaudis l'Académie
pour m'avoir retiré mon droit  à la liberté d'expression,
je vous ai prévenu que si vous ne levez pas
vos sanctions et ne me rendez pas mes billets
avant midi.  dimanche, vous ferez face à
des conséquences inimaginables de plus
c'est un acte d'agression que personne dans les
films n'a été reconnu par l'
Académie où sont les nominations pour
des films classiques comme quand Harry a
kidnappé Sally vous avez une bombe postale ou la
planète des viols en haut  de tout
cela,
j'ai payé deux millions de dollars à hilary swank
pour être mon rendez-vous et elle ne remboursera pas un
sou mon calendrier du dimanche est maintenant aussi
vide qu'une épicerie nord-coréenne mais
quoi qu'il arrive, je prévois toujours d'assister à
l'after party du réalisateur Brett Ratner
puisque c'est  impossible d'attraper l'herpès
deux fois
mort à l'ouest mort à l'Amérique et
bonne chance Billy Crystal est un fantastique
comment était-ce que j'avais l'air assez fou